التغيرات في الضغط الجوي ودرجات
الحرارة المرتفعة للغاية والتهديد
بالجفاف، نضع كل ذلك معًا
والمرضى الذين يعانون من الصداع النصفي سيشهدون
فجأة زيادة في الصداع أو
تواتر الصداع النصفي خلال هذه الأحداث،
يقول الدكتور أحمد استمالك من كليفلاند كلينك إن أولئك الذين يعانون من
الصداع النصفي المزمن المستمر سيشعرون أكثر من غيرهم  من المحتمل أن يتطلب الأمر
حقنًا دوائية يومية أو إجراءً، ولكن
بالنسبة لأولئك الذين يصابون بها بشكل أقل،
يمكنك إدارة الصداع النصفي عن طريق معرفة
مسبباتك وتجنبها والبقاء
رطبًا، كما يقول ديموليك، إن ذلك وحده قد
يزيل احتمالية الإصابة بالصداع النصفي، ثم
يتحول أخيرًا إلى دواء الإنقاذ في أقرب وقت.
تبدأ الأعراض ولكنه يحذر من
تناول هذه الأدوية عدة مرات في
الأسبوع، ونوصي عادةً بما لا يزيد عن
مرتين إلى ثلاث مرات فقط لأن
هؤلاء المرضى الذين يعانون من الصداع النصفي
يتعرضون لخطر الإصابة بما نسميه
الصداع الارتدادي إذا استخدموا
الأدوية المجهضة أيضًا.  في كثير من الأحيان، وإذا كنت
تعاني من
الصداع النصفي العقلي المرتبط بالحرارة، يقول تقديري أن تطلب الرعاية،
على الرغم من كونه
منتشرًا للغاية، إلا أنه يظل تحت التشخيص
الخاطئ وغالبًا ما يتم علاجه
أيضًا، لذا مرة أخرى لا يحتاج المرضى إلى
المعاناة، تحدث إلى مقدم الرعاية الصحية
الخاص بك  طبيب أعصاب أو
متخصص في الصداع لأن هناك الكثير
مما يمكن أن يحدث فرقًا في
الصحة، أنا آندي جايثر